[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
IEIN VALDEZ: We're live?
Awesome.
Hey, everyone.
This is Iein Valdez, with the
Google App Engine developer
relations team.
And we're here today
to talk about
Cloud SQL and App Engine.
And we're pretty excited
about Cloud SQL for
a variety of reasons.
In particular we had the
DataStore, which was a great,
non-relational data store--
super scalable, really, really
great way to persist
your data.
But we had a lot of developers
that wanted to use
traditional, relational
databases.
And so late last year we
announced Cloud SQL.
And so we're here to talk
about Cloud SQL.
I've got a couple of my
colleagues from Google.
I have Joe Faith, who's the
product manager for Cloud SQL.
I have Wally, who's also on
the engineering team.
So we're going to
talk about it.
And why don't we get started?
We have some slides that Wally's
going to put up, and
then Joe's going to give us a
quick introduction to what
Cloud SQL is, some of
the highlights.
And then we're going to talk
a little bit about--
we have a presentation to show
you some of the strengths,
some of the interesting tidbits,
and then we're
actually going to go into
some code samples.
And then we'll come back to Q&A.
So go to the moderator
link as we go through.
If you have questions about
anything, just go ahead and
put the questions in the
moderator, and then I'll come
back and make sure that
we answer them all.
All right, why don't
we kick it off?
Joe?
JOE FAITH: So we know that
Google's got this phenomenal
infrastructure--
the infrastructure we built up
for Gmail, and for search.
And the question that we've
always been asking ourselves
on the Cloud team is, how
do we take that awesome
infrastructure and package it
in such a way so that you
guys-- external developers-- can
make the best use of it?
We want you guys to share the
infrastructure that we take
advantage of every day.
App Engine has been a great
success in how to do that.
It packages up the power of the
infrastructure we've got.
So that it's scalable, but built
on standard languages--
like Java and Python--
which makes it a lot easier for
you guys to get started.
As Iein mentioned, the data
store has been a key part of
the success of App Engine.
You just find it so easy to
get started, with the
scalability.
You just don't have to worry
about some of the scalability
issues you do with some of
the other data sources.
But we heard you guys
saying, we want SQL.
It's familiar, we've built so
many applications on it.
And it's got some key features
that you just can't get with
another SQL data store.
It's got your robust schemas.
It's got your generalized
queries.
You've got your transactions,
and of course DataStore does a
certain amount of that.
But there's always stuff that
you want out of SQL.
We listened, and we thought very
carefully about how to
package up a true relational
database to take advantage of
Google's infrastructure, and
which fit in with the App
Engine ecosystem.
And Cloud SQL is what
we came up with.
We had a few key
design choices.
The first was, which database.
There's an awful lot
of them out there.
We went and initially
with MySQL.
It's the most popular open
source one out there.
So many of you are familiar with
it, and it's matured a
great deal.
It is now a robust enterprise
class database.
In some ways, it was
the obvious choice.
The other choices we wanted to
make were we wanted to get
very nice integration with the
existing App Engine ecosystem.
That meant using standard
drivers from
Java, and from Python--
JDBC, Python DB-API--
but at the same time
make it managed.
We know what a headache
managing any kind of
database can be.
You've got your security
updates, your versions,
managing access.
We've all been there.
We've all carried the pager.
Basically we're now carrying
the pager for you guys.
No more calls at 2 o'clock
in the morning.
We also thought very carefully
about replication model.
We care a great deal
about your data.
Over the years at Google, we've
learned an awful lot
about replication, about data
durability, and the
importance of it.
When you're carrying people's
data at the scale that we are
in Google, it becomes
second nature.
You don't take any risks
with the data.
That's why we went with the
decision to, as standard, make
your data multiply replicated
across multiple data centers.
There's two underlying
reasons for that.
And they often get conflated
and confused.
The first one is data
durability.
When you insert data into a
Cloud SQL database, and you
return the call with an
[INAUDIBLE], saying yes, we've
got your data, we have got your
data in multiple places,
in multiple systems, in
multiple locations.
This is synchronous
replication.
We're then at a position where
we're robust against very,
very large outages.
If a farmer plows up a main
network cable, or hunters
shoot down the cable-- and
they have done this.
Hunters seem to take great
delight in shooting down
network cable.
Even if that happens, your
data will be safe.
Not only will it be safe--
and we're all familiar with the
idea of taking backups, as
our grandfathers and
grandmothers tell us, keep
taking backups.
Not only do we have to take
backups, but this also means
that your data is available.
If a hunter gets trigger happy
somewhere in the United
States, there'll be another data
center that can take up
the load with no loss
of availability.
So it's durability and
availability built in a standard.
That was a very important
design principle for us.
We've noticed that
organizations, enterprises,
businesses, put the data they
really care about in the
relational database because of
the aspects like transaction
processing.
That's obviously why safe
financial institutions opt for
relational data stores.
So the last issue
is over pricing.
And we wanted to work out, how
can we make best advantage of
our durable, available,
distributed, replicated
architecture.
But then make that available to
you in the way that you'd
be happy with.
And a key aspect is what we
call per use pricing.
Now often, when you're buying
up a relational database
service, you're paying from
the moment you create that
database to the moment that
you delete it and
lose all your data.
In the case of Cloud SQL,
we've got what we
call per use pricing.
That means you're only paying
for the time when your
database is actually
being accessed.
If a database is cold, and
you're not using it, then
you're not paying
for that access.
And that was a key
decision for us.
It means that if you're just
trying out a system, if you
want to see it's going to be
suitable for a particular
project, create your database,
play around with it--
don't have to delete your data,
don't have to get rid of
it-- but if you're not using
it, you won't be paying.
That's per use pricing.
We've also got packages if
you've decided, yes, that
Cloud SQL is going to fit for
your application, then we've
got packages which make
it cheaper to use on
a persistent basis.
But those are some of the key
design decisions we took when
making Cloud SQL.
And I think it's worked
out quite well.
IEIN VALDEZ: What I think is
really great about the way
Cloud SQL is implemented, was
that it's very similar to the
App Engine model, which is sort
of easy to use, easy to
manage, easy to scale.
And that ease of use
from a SQL--
because I remember
managing a SQL
database was always painful.
And I think the managed service
part of Cloud SQL is
actually super important.
And as we kind of go through and
show you some of the-- we
made it really easy to manage.
But I think it is important to
also think about, you can
actually mix and match
these models.
So you may need DataStore for
certain things, but you also
may need a relational
database.
And we can use the
two together.
JOE FAITH: In some ways--
that's a very good point.
We've had quite a
few questions.
Well, which should I use?
And there are advantages and
disadvantages of both.
IEIN VALDEZ: There's a good
Google I/O talk on this.
I think it's from
the Battle of--
JOE FAITH: Battle
of the Backends.
IEIN VALDEZ: Battle of the
Backends, where it compares
Cloud SQL and SQL.
It's got two engineering teams
competing with each other.
JOE FAITH: It's actually
funny.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, it
is a comedy routine.
JOE FAITH: You may not believe
me, but a debate about no SQL
versus SQL relational data
models can be funny.
IEIN VALDEZ: It's definitely
worthwhile to look at.
But it is easy to mix and match
the two and use them.
I've done it before.
I think the last thing you might
want to point out is
that the other nice thing is,
it's super easy to make them
talk to each other.
Maybe Wally will talk
about this.
We'll see in the code.
But I think the authentication
part is actually--
it's really easy to connect
your App Engine app
right into Cloud SQL.
You don't have to manage
a bunch of nonsense.
You connect them.
JOE FAITH: No more nonsense.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yes.
Nonsense is no good.
So maybe let's switch over.
Wally, do you want to kind of
walk us through a couple
different slides you can talk
a little bit about?
WALLY YAU: Sure.
Let me go through
this slide here.
The first slide I'm going
over is Getting Started.
How do you start using
the Cloud SQL.
So to sign in actually is
really straightforward.
What you do is you go to the
Google API console, and once
you log onto the console,
you go to the services.
Then you will see there's
an option for
turning on Cloud SQL.
So maybe I can step through
real quick here.
So here I have an account that
I logged on already.
So I go to code.google.com
API's console here.
So this is my console here.
So if you click on the services
tab here, then you
will be able to see
the Cloud SQL.
IEIN VALDEZ: And it's likely,
Wally, that if you've written
against any Google APIs, you
probably already have access
to the console today.
So it should be familiar.
WALLY YAU: So here, if you have
pricing defined already,
then you can just click on
and turn it on here.
Once you turn on your Cloud SQL,
then all you have to do
is to install the Google
App Engine SDK.
And install the Google
plug-in for Eclipse.
And you're all set to go.
And that's all you have to do.
IEIN VALDEZ: And there's
a good tutorial online
for that, as well.
WALLY YAU: So once you went from
the API console, you can
actually create a Cloud
SQL instance.
So from here, in this screen
shot here, you can see that I
have three instances
created here.
And there's a way to save
new instance right here.
And then when you select a new
instance, it allows you to
select four different sizes,
ranging from D1
all the way to D4.
On the screen you can see the
differences between D1 and D4.
So for D1, it's the smaller one
that gives you 0.5GB of
ram and 1GB of storage.
All the way up to D4, which
gives you 4GB of ram and 10GB
of storage here.
So once you set up all the
database instance, then you
can configure access.
In one of the access control, it
allows you to specify which
Google App Engine application
you can allow to access that
particular MySQL instance.
So let me see if I can go to.
So this is one of the Cloud SQL
database that I have here.
And if I go back to this
instance here, if you scroll
down here, then you
can see this
authorize application here.
You just select, and it allows
you to specify the Google App
Engine application that you
allow to access that instance
of the database.
IEIN VALDEZ: And you can have
multiple App Engine apps
share, right?
WALLY YAU: From here, you can
see here, that you can
associate more than one
application here.
So you can see on the [? data ?]
box, you have one
here and then you
have two here.
So you can associate multiple
instances of the app to each
instance of the MySQL
database.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool.
WALLY YAU: So the next I want to
show is a live application.
So this is actually a
Google App Engine
application that I wrote.
[TYPING]
So at Google, we
have a problem.
We actually allow people to ride
bikes between buildings,
and a lot of times the
bike will be broken.
But there's no good way to
report the broken bike.
So what people do is they just
take out their seat and then
they just put it in
the bike basket.
But I have this idea of writing
an app that allow
people to take a picture.
And when they take a picture,
the broken bike
will go to App Engine.
And then the App Engine will
store in the MySQL database.
So here, you can have some
sample data that you can see
on the screen.
So each marker represents
a broken bike.
So if you click on the marker
here, and then just pull out
the picture of the broken bike,
and then you will see
who reports it and
the data report,
the day of the incident.
IEIN VALDEZ: Did you build
this in Java or Python?
WALLY YAU: I built
this in Java.
So I'm going to show
you some code here.
IEIN VALDEZ: Okay, cool.
WALLY YAU: So the code is very
straightforward here.
I have a JSP page called
Gbike.jsp.
So in the Gbike.jsp here, this
is the page that actually gets
the list of broken bikes and
then display on the map.
So I wrap the database in Java
technology based GIDB, and
here is really important.
I create a connection first.
I used the standard Java manager
to get a connection to
the database.
And then I call my database
object, and then get the list
of broken bikes.
JOE FAITH: So all that's
just vanilla JSP?
WALLY YAU: Yes, vanilla
JSP, yeah.
JOE FAITH: So that could
be running on anything?
WALLY YAU: Right.
So if you look at the method
to get a broken bike, it's
really just straightforward.
It's just select statement right
here, and then prepare
the statement, and then execute
it against the database.
IEIN VALDEZ: So anyone that's
built JSPs or JDBCs, it should
be second nature to
be able to use it.
JOE FAITH: It'd be
trivial to pull
stuff over to the platform.
WALLY YAU: So there's something
that I want to point
out right here, is
the connection.
So it is recommend that you
create a connection at the
beginning of the servlet, and
then after you're done with
it, you close the connection.
And there's a reason for it.
Because the way the MySQL
database that's running on the
Cloud is very different than the
MySQL that you run on the
local instance.
So when you set up a local box,
you install your local
MySQL instance.
That instance will always
run as long as your
box is up and running.
But in the case of MySQL running
on the Cloud, if
you're instance is idol, we will
conserve it, and we'll
take it down and put
it to sleep.
So say if you try to hold onto
a connection for too long,
your instance of the MySQL
running on the Cloud may not
be up anymore.
So if you try to use the
connection again, you will get
an invalid connection
in that case.
JOE FAITH: It's worth pointing
out that this idea of not
using connection pooling, a
pattern that we've all been
familiar with.
If you're using connection
pooling, you'd still have to
test every connection.
Now on MySQL, it takes as long
to test a connection as it
does to create one.
So this method is just as fast
as connection pooling.
You're not losing
any performance.
IEIN VALDEZ: I think it's even
a little bit faster.
Just a tiny bit.
It's just so much faster just
to open a brand new
connection.
JOE FAITH: It then makes
the application so
much easier to manage.
You can take it up
and take it down.
IEIN VALDEZ: Well and your
data center may go away
somewhere, and your applications
seamlessly work
somewhere else.
That is the benefit of Cloud,
you just don't know.
Very cool.
Now, did you have to put in--
I can't see the screen
from here-- but did
you have to put a--
you don't have to put
a username and
password in there right--
WALLY YAU: No, I don't.
IEIN VALDEZ: --to connect?
Because that's part of
when you initially
created that link.
It makes it really
easy to use.
JOE FAITH: It's a very robust
security model actually,
directly authorized from
that application.
IEIN VALDEZ: Now what
about users?
You can give it to
applications,
right, in this case?
But we can also give
it to users, right?
If you want to be able to
use maybe some of the
command line tools.
JOE FAITH: On that G-byte thing,
it's worth pointing
out, that we're using Cloud
SQL widely internally.
We're using it all over the
place within Google.
The Org Chart is in Cloud SQL.
So Larry Page is CEO because of
Cloud SQL, I like to think.
IEIN VALDEZ: Well yeah, we like
to use our own technology
stuff, and we do have a need
for relational databases
inside of Google as well.
WALLY YAU: OK, so the other
thing I'd like to show is how
easy it is to use a command
prompt to log onto the
instance of the MySQL.
IEIN VALDEZ: There
we go, cool.
WALLY YAU: So here, Google
actually provided a command
show utility that you can use.
To use it, all you have to do
is to download the package,
and then specify the name of
your database instance.
So on the screen, I have
that all ready to go.
IEIN VALDEZ: The instance
is waking up maybe.
WALLY YAU: OK, so once the
command comes back, this is
very familiar--
SQL, greater-than sign here.
So you can say, show database.
OK, so these are very,
very familiar to you.
It's just a standard SQL syntax
that you can use.
IEIN VALDEZ: And you can use
this command tool for
scripting as well, right?
Like if you want to write
scripts to export things.
I remember in my old SQL days
I used to do a lot of
scripting, and have to get
things in and out.
JOE FAITH: You'll end up doing
a lot less of that.
Because there are tools for,
say, importing and
exporting the data.
And they enter into
Cloud storage.
WALLY YAU: OK, so just to show
you how I can import the
database very easily, I have
here a database schema, a
sample database schema.
So in this sample database
schema, I have
about close to 80 tables.
And you can see the
schema here.
So one thing I want to point
out here-- if you look
carefully here--
when I do a MySQL dump on the
original database schema that
I have, the engine is
all set to MyISAM.
So I took the care--
I actually changed all of MyISAM
table into the InnoDB
table, and there's
a reason for it.
The reason is that MyISAM
performance is very, very slow
compared to InnoDB
on the Cloud SQL.
So you have to make sure
that you use InnoDB.
JOE FAITH: And you don't have
the same referential integrity
constraints.
For a whole bunch of reasons,
stick with InnoDB.
WALLY YAU: So, in order to
import this database schema
into the Cloud SQL, all I have
to do is to do the same thing.
So I run my Cloud SQL command
prompt, specify my instance,
and then just redirect my
SQL schema in there.
And then they'll be chunking.
Because there's close to 80
tables, it's going to take
about a few minutes.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
I'm sorry, I can't see
from here, but what
exactly are you importing?
WALLY YAU: It's the database
schema that I exported from.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, from
another database.
So you're just importing it.
Now can you--
let's say I'm a developer and
I have MySQL on my desktop--
can I import my MySQL backup
into Cloud SQL?
JOE FAITH: Yeah, you can take
a dump from your local
machine, and import it-- upload
into Cloud Storage.
IEIN VALDEZ: And actually
it's worth
pointing out Cloud Storage.
I don't know if we talked
about that.
But it may or may not be
apparent, but one of the nice
things is this is also linked
into Cloud Storage.
You can use Cloud Storage to
take backups of your data, and
dump them in there so you
can pull them later.
JOE FAITH: Yeah, you can take
an import and export
any time you like.
We've also got managed backups,
which we take, and
you take them--
might be included as part of
seven backups stored, which
are done in a scheduled
manner.
You can restore from any of
those, as well as getting your
data in and out.
IEIN VALDEZ: In and out.
Yeah, it's a good mechanism
for moving
data back and forth.
JOE FAITH: It tends to be a
little bit quicker than doing
it from the command line.
WALLY YAU: Oh yeah, because of
the network traffic that you
have to go through.
JOE FAITH: That's a nice use of
how you can just use your
standard MySQL scripting.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, so if you
have scripts that you've
already built to get certain
stats out, or data out, or
import/export stuff, you
can sort of reuse that.
WALLY YAU: So the import
process just finished.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, cool.
So we can check it out?
WALLY YAU: Yeah, we
can check it out.
IEIN VALDEZ: We don't have
to, I believe you.
JOE FAITH: I believe him.
I believe him.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool.
The other thing that's actually
worth pointing out--
there's a tutorial for this, as
well-- but you can also, if
you have Java tools
that use JDBC.
So for instance, SQL scroll,
what is it called?
JOE FAITH: Yeah, there's
a bunch of SQL scroll.
IEIN VALDEZ: Anything that uses
a JDBC driver, you can
basically, if you have a tool
that you use to manage your
data, and it has the ability to
use a standard JDBC driver,
we can basically plug that in.
JOE FAITH: Crystal report,
full standard [INAUDIBLE]
and report.
IEIN VALDEZ: So that's another
nice benefit, I think, that
maybe doesn't come
across a lot.
Cool.
Did you have anything
else, Wally, you
wanted to talk about?
WALLY YAU: I think that's
all I have.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, great.
This is awesome.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at some of the questions
people have.
I have our Google
Moderator here.
It looks like we have nine
questions from the audience.
So we'll go ahead and
go through these.
I'll just ask the question
out loud and you
guys can jump at it.
So the first question is,
considering a scenario that
one has a website serving an
application using Java MySQL
and it's not being migrated, how
will MySQL go in the App
Engine database?
I think this is just
an export question.
JOE FAITH: Yes.
I think there might be slight
confusion when talking about
App Engine database.
Do they mean DataStore?
IEIN VALDEZ: DataStore, OK.
JOE FAITH: Yeah.
DataStore is your
no SQL database.
Cloud SQL is a SQL database,
hence the name.
So the MySQL wouldn't go
into the DataStore.
IEIN VALDEZ: It would go
into the Cloud SQL.
Yeah, so it would go from MySQL,
your server, into the
Cloud SQL, which
is equivalent.
WALLY YAU: I hope the demo that
I just did will answer
his question as well.
Just to show you how easy
it is to import
the data from SQL.
JOE FAITH: If you go to the
Cloud SQL homepage, click
under tools and resources.
There's a page on how to import
and export your database.
It's very straightforward.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
OK, great.
The next question
is from Hector.
It's triggers and stored
procedures, is it supported?
If so, what kind of interaction
can we implement
within the App Engine code?
I have some thoughts on
this, but maybe you
guys have some more.
JOE FAITH: I'm just thinking
Hector's in Martinique.
If he invites us out
there, then we'll
demonstrate it in person.
IEIN VALDEZ: Exactly.
JOE FAITH: So triggers and
stored procedures, yes,
they're supported.
We don't support user
defined functions.
There's a couple of things like
that which, purely for
Cloud security, were
implemented.
But triggers and stored
procedures are.
What kind of interaction can we
implement within App Engine?
I'm just tempted to say all the
standard stuff you do from
an application in
Java and Python.
IEIN VALDEZ: It should work
JOE FAITH: Cascade deletes,
auto updates.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, anything you
would open a connection to
the database and execute
a query, right?
The same thing should work
here, so that's cool.
A slightly unrelated question,
from [? Levee ?], which is
would you please consider
adding a pricing
calculator for GAE.
And I think this is a
really great idea.
I think we've been wanting
to do this for a while.
I'll go back and talk to
the team about it.
It probably would be good to
have a pricing calculator for
Cloud SQL, potentially,
though it seems pretty
straightforward to me.
JOE FAITH: Yes.
It's a slightly different
pricing model, because we
listened to how people are
wanting to use it.
The preference within
App Engine--
everything managed, you
want your quotas.
Within Cloud SQL, you don't
particularly want your
instance to be turned off
by [INTERPOSING VOICES].
So it's a slightly different
pricing model because that's
how people were using
it differently.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, cool.
We have a question from
Muhammed, which is, I want to
use Jango on App Engine
with Cloud SQL.
What's the maximum number of
concurrent requests that can
be serviced?
Let's start there.
I have some thoughts
on this, but do you
guys have any thoughts?
JOE FAITH: Firstly, yes.
There's an article on using
Jango on App Engine.
IEIN VALDEZ: The getting
started guide, yes.
JOE FAITH: Yes.
And Jango is a really nice
framework for Python.
But whenever you start using a
framework, you get a trade off
between performance and
productivity and ease of use.
And there is that trade
off with Jango.
It adds extra overhead.
To the maximum concurrent
requests that can be
responsibly served--
how long is a piece of string?
It depends so much on the
particular application.
I really suggest trying it
out with your particular
application.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, I would say
benchmark it, for sure, and
just see what ceiling you hit.
And there's a bunch of
strategies to sort of get
around that.
You can add more instances.
You're not just tied to a
single instance, right?
You can actually shard
instances.
I've seen people
do this before.
Wally might have some
other thoughts.
WALLY YAU: Isn't there a maximum
connections that we
can have for My SQL?
JOE FAITH: Yes.
Around a hundred.
But that's more of a question
of performance rather than
just the concurrent connections,
I think.
IEIN VALDEZ: I would say
to try to benchmark.
I think that's probably
the best way.
And then if you do run into
issues, there's a couple
different ways you
can interact.
We have a discussion
group, and we
also use stack overflow.
So there's a Cloud SQL tag on
stack overflow and an App
Engine tag.
So if you definitely have
questions, or you're running
into problems, post to the
community or back to the
discussion group.
JOE FAITH: I think there's a
wider point in general about
the different philosophies
between no SQL and SQL.
In some ways, people have made a
little sport with DataStore,
because it is so scalable.
You can just throw queries out
at it, and you just won't see
any difference.
Cloud SQL, because it's a
relation, because it has
robust acid transactions, it's
more of a fixed pipe.
In order to maintain those
acidic transactions, there are
more limits on what it can do.
Therefore, it's always
advisable, during load testing
with any new application.
Especially if you're expecting
a big peak in traffic.
We wouldn't want to get you
slashdotted and hurt.
It also reflects the type of
applications that each one is
more suitable for.
If you've got an application
where you want to do some kind
of locking, you're just dumping
data, very, very fast
reads, to a data store,
DataStore
would be a better fit.
If you've got much more
structured data that you want
to do many more generalized
queries on, but don't want to
worry about maintaining your own
indexes, Cloud SQL would
be more suitable.
Think carefully about what's
going to be the most suitable
way of storing your data.
As I mentioned, there's that
great talk from Google I/O. If
you go to the Google I/O
videos, look for
Battle of the Backends.
They go through a few
key use cases there.
IEIN VALDEZ: The one other
interesting part of this
question, which is asking about
if the app was database
read or write intensive,
or read intensive.
But I think the crux of the
question was sort of toward
the end, which is what happens
if traffic exceeds that limit?
Do we throw exceptions, or how
do we throttle that back?
JOE FAITH: It will degrade
gracefully up to the point at
which your App Engine responses
are timing out.
IEIN VALDEZ: Okay, cool.
All right, we have another
question here from
[? Castoob. ?]
I apologize if I didn't
say your name right.
The question is, considering
a scenario where there's a
website serving an application
using Java MySQL and it now
needs to be migrated
to App Engine--
oh this seems a duplicate
question, or it moved.
OK, this is real time.
So there we go.
It's humor for the day.
How do I implement parallel
authorization for my App
Engine app with Google ID along
with my website ID?
How does that concept work?
I think the question here
is about using the
Google users service--
the user API-- to basically
authorize a Gmail user, or a
Google Apps domain, with
the application.
But I don't think that concept
falls down into the database,
unless you want to explicitly
authorize.
JOE FAITH: As with the rest of
the console, you can authorize
individual users to
read or write.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, I don't think
it makes sense to say
all 100 people in the domain
would get access.
You would have to manually
authorize it, I think, if I
understand the question
correctly.
But there's good documentation
on the users' API for both
Python and Java.
And then you can also look at
the section on authorization
for Cloud SQL.
It does talk about per app, as
well as individual users.
Is it possible to integrate
an app running on AWS
to use Cloud SQL.
JOE FAITH: Yes.
We've got JDBC, and
that will work.
Always bear in mind that if
you're running applications on
a different network to, or
remotely from, the database,
the new latency, you'll
take a hit there.
But yes, certainly possible.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, cool.
So you can use Cloud SQL from
other Cloud services.
JOE FAITH: Yeah, from
anywhere else.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, great.
OK, let's see.
What do you call--
I'm trying to intuiting this
question here-- which is what
do you call a product developed
on App Engine as a
whole, in terms of Cloud--
infrastructure as a service,
platform as a service, or
software as a service?
I think this is generically
talking about App Engine.
App Engine's platform
is a service, right?
So there's no infrastructure
you run or manage.
You write your code.
And Cloud SQL fits into
that bucket as well.
JOE FAITH: Yes.
It takes away that layer
of headache.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, you're
not managing a Cloud
SQL server or instance.
You're not backing it up, you're
not starting, stopping,
maintenance.
These are all part of in the
platform as a service sweep,
where it's really focused on
developer productivity.
WALLY YAU: Isn't there a term
called DBS service?
IEIN VALDEZ: There is also
database as a service.
I've heard that as well.
Yeah, exactly.
I think they're all in
the platform layer.
OK, great.
Totally unrelated question
about four Nexus devices
showed up in my Gmail account.
I'm not sure what
this is about.
So we're just going
skip over it.
He's asking for an option
to troubleshoot.
I would say, take a look at the
Android developers page.
I'm sure there's some support
forums there somewhere.
And this last one doesn't--
it's just a website link.
So I think we have got
all of the questions.
I'm going to double check that
nothing popped up here.
JOE FAITH: Triggers,
stored procedures.
Good to go.
Pricing calculator,
good suggestion.
Jango, yes.
It's a very nice framework,
but you might take a
performance hit.
You should try it out
for yourself.
IEIN VALDEZ: Oh, OK,
here's a new one.
How will multiple requests be
handled on the same database
and table in Cloud SQL?
JOE FAITH: It's the same as
standard MySQL, so that
they're mutually exclusive
[INAUDIBLE] box.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool.
I think we got all of
the questions here.
This is great.
I'm really happy.
People can go to learn more at
developers.google.com/cloudsql.
There's an active developer
forum, as well as the App
Engine forum, you can
post as well.
The last question I have for
you, Joe, and I don't know
what you have cooking.
Do you have any glimpse of the
future of Cloud SQL, any new
stuff coming out?
If not, that's cool, but I just
always like to ask for
the audience.
JOE FAITH: The main thing our
guys have been working on for
the last few months have been
performance, performance,
performance.
And you should see some good
improvement, including things
like making backups
a lot faster.
We've got some interesting
stuff in the works, just
around the corner.
I was really hoping to be
able to talk more about
them, but not yet.
IEIN VALDEZ: All right,
well cool.
We love Hangouts.
It's a great vehicle to
communicate with people.
And so we'll have you on again
as a special guest host.
JOE FAITH: Especially when
we go to Martinique.
I think we should take the
road show to Martinique.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yes, OK, awesome.
I agree with you.
We need to do these
things remotely.
And we'll have to bring our
illustrious studio here.
JOE FAITH: That'd be a good
demonstration of the
technology.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yes, exactly.
I guess with that we'll go ahead
and wrap up and close
this GDL session.
I want to thank everyone,
and our guests
here, Wally and Joe.
Thank you for making some
time and stay tuned.
Keep an eye out.
We'll have some more App Engine
Hangouts coming on in
the next couple of weeks.
So thanks everyone, and
I'm going to sign off.
So long.
[MUSIC PLAYING]